new england patriots there's been a lot
of talk about cam newton and whether or
not he will be back jared stidham is the
other option brian hoyer i think blew
his chance with that brain uh issue that
he had i guess i could say brain fart
that he had wrong with that against the
chiefs on that monday night game uh how
likely do you think it is that cam
newton is back there there was reporting
near the end of the season no way no how
cam sure sounds like a guy who'd be
interested i i think so and i i i don't
think that's out of the realm of
possibilities i don't um i still think
there's some positives about what cam
newton did last year in a very tough
environment and i do think you know some
of his issues can are fixable
i don't look at it that way you know
again it's a little bit like we talked
about with like the 49ers and jimmy
garoppolo i mean first off
you know where they are in the draft and
everything like that they could be in no
man's land for the quarterback again
you're not you they might have to make a
move if they want to think about
drafting one of these quarterbacks so
you know where does that go and then out
there in free agency
you know again just show me some better
options i don't think they're the type
of team that's going to trade the house
or the farm for a desean watson or
russell wilson i don't think so that's
usually not been in the dna of the the
new england patriots you know i've heard
the marcus mariota thing that makes
sense for the way their team is built
right now you know he can do some of
that cam newton stuff and all of those
type of things with the way they run the
football
but i i will not be shocked to see cam
newton back there and the big thing is
of course as we know they need to get
some weapons to help
i don't care who's that quarterback it's
going to be tough sledding up there
unless they start to get some receivers
who can get open once in a while
there's a report from nfl media that the
trade interest generally in marcus
mariota has cooled you mentioned him as
a potential patriots quarterback 10.725
million dollar compensation package
again
in this climate with the cap shrinking
they may have a hard time getting anyone
to take on that number they may have to
cut him or or keep him but that's an
expensive backup if derek carr is your
guy and he's making about 20 this year
and you're paying mario to half of that
and and if you know if if your car at
some point you're going to say to john
gruden and or mike mayo i could find
your guy why do you have this other guy
who's making eight figures uh it may be
they just have to cut him loose if they
can't find a trade partner
there's no reason for him to reduce his
salary to facilitate a trade and then
maybe he signs with the patriots on the
open market i mean they paid cam newton
last year right with all the incentives
tallied up 3.7
million dollars think about that even
though they didn't get the playoffs that
is a hell of a bargain for the
quarterback position for the new england
patriots and that's just more money they
have going into this year's cap that
they didn't spend on cam newton and the
quarterback position last year yeah no i
i know it is amazing it really is
they're they're they're in a predicament
as far as this quarterback situation you
know is considered you know they got
jared said them okay great he can be the
backup but you know the way it looked
last year hey that's one i was wrong
about evaluating the quarterback you
want to sit here and you know hey chris
sims is wrong about jared syndrome i was
expecting to see more there's no doubt
about it when he did get his
opportunities and obviously there's
something there missing in his game
either way too because they never felt
the need to really want to put him in
there for cam newton whether it's the
person the player whatever i don't know
um but but the team itself
you know
quarterback yes wide receiver we know
how much can some of all these opt outs
help their football team as they come
back you know you know again patrick
chung was up there in years as it was
you know a year off from now playing
football dante hightower you know again
up there a lot and a physical middle
linebacker like a a car crash middle
linebacker what's he going to be like
coming back they got all this money
secondary is good but they do got to
find some different makers on their
front seven i mean
as we saw when they played teams that
were good up front like the rams with
their running game and the bootlegs and
those things and the 49ers and what they
did they were so outmatched they
couldn't even they couldn't stop them
for anything they did whatever they want
so they have to improve uh a few areas
on their football team to kind of get
back in the you know the upper echelons
we're going to
what was that echelon
are you sure no i'm not you know we do
have we do have the evidence oh we do
this thing recording oh okay because
here's the thing last week when we had
miles simmons on he used upper echelon
and i said how refreshing it is to have
someone who nails it on the first try
thank you and and and uh you you're
still we're it's still a work in
progress when you carry around that many
years the mistaken belief that it's
upper echelons yeah it is kind of hard
to break the habit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports